according to joe biden it's the never  trump republicans which makes up i think  about seven people at this point the  never trump republicans they're the  mainstream biden just tweeted out quote  in this moment those who love this  country democrats independents and  mainstream republicans must be stronger  more determined and more committed to  saving america than mega republicans are  to destroying america what percentage of  the republican party is never trump the  most  generous  wild statistics on this would say about  six percent or so 94 of republicans  support trump at least and really i bet  the number is even higher than that and  yet according to biden that that six  percent tops that's the mainstream the  rest of you virtually half the country  we're the fringe we're the radicals  we're trying to destroy america half  this country according to biden and  we've got to essentially be kept out of  the electoral system